Les pêcheurs de Karachi la considèrent
comme un don de Dieu,
Qui regorge de poissons et de crustacés.
Un paradis prospère qui s'étale sur
des centaines de milliers d'hectares,
jusqu'aux portes de la ville.
La mangrove de Karachi était l'une
des cinq plus grandes au monde.
Mais aujourd'hui, ceux qui en vivent
sont inquiets.
La mangrove, leur mangrove disent-ils,
est en train de disparaître,
Contrairement aux apparences.
Assif et Mohamed en sont convaincus.
Originaire de Manorin, un des
quartiers historiques de la ville,
Ils nous emmènent ce matin
à quelques encablures du port,
Là où ils pêchent depuis leur enfance.
Voilà, c'est là. Regardez.
Allez, coupe le moteur.
On va passer par là.
Pour nous y rendre, il nous faut plonger
au cœur des arbres,
Et glisser parmi les branchages denses.
Avant de découvrir une première clairière.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ici ?
Regardez, cette partie a été complètement
détruite par les coupeurs de bois.
Tout a été saccagé.
Sur plusieurs hectares, nous découvrons des
centaines d'arbres mutilés, tronçonnés,
coupés à leur base.
Plus nous progressons, plus nous
constatons l'étendue des dégâts.
Tout cet endroit était
couvert de mangrove.
Il y avait tellement d'arbres qu'on ne
pouvait même pas venir jusqu'en bateaux.
Avant, on venait là pour
s'amuser et pêcher.
On se reposait à l'ombre des arbres.
Mais au rythme où les coupeurs opèrent,
bientôt, il n'y aura plus rien,
Plus de poisson, plus que de la boue.
Moi, je suis fou de rage.
Si je pouvais,
je tuerai ceux qui ont fait ça.
Ils ont tout détruit à jamais.
Et nous, on ne peut rien faire
parce qu'on est des pauvres pêcheurs.
Nous avons tenté
d'alerter les autorités,
Mais personne ne semble
concerné par tout ça.
Cette année, Assif et Mohamed ont décidé
de changer de zone de pêche.
Crabes et crevettes ne remplissent
plus leurs filets,
Ils ont disparu avec les arbres.
Ces cinq dernières années, disent-ils,
ils ont assisté, impuissants,
À la destruction de plus de 150 hectares
de forêts de mangrove.
À Karachi, plus de 150 000 personnes,
Vivent des fruits, de la pêche
et des cultures de la mangrove.
Une mangrove nourricière qui a
accompagné le développement de la ville,
aujourd'hui bordée au nord et au sud par les
deux plus importants ports de pêche,
De tout le pays.
Ici, dans celui de Korangi.
Les pêcheurs ont décidé de
se mobiliser pour la protéger.
Hussein et Kamal sont membres de la
plus importante fédération du port,
Qui compte plus de 10 000 membres.
Depuis quelques mois, ils sillonnent la mangrove
à la rencontre de ceux qui la détruisent,
Pour tenter de leur faire prendre
conscience des dégâts qu'ils commettent.
Nous débarquons sur l'île de Bhit.
Un kilomètre au large de Karachi.
Selon leurs dernières informations, des
coupeurs opéreraient ici depuis une semaine.
Il faut s'enfoncer discrètement,
pour ne pas les faire fuir.
Couper du bois de mangrove
est une activité illégale,
Passible de plusieurs mois d'emprisonnement.
Ça vient de là.
Là-bas aussi.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Il y a quelqu'un qui coupe.
Là, on l'entend.
De ce côté,
Et de l'autre aussi.
C'est là !
Allons-y !
Sur notre passage,
Du bois fraîchement coupé.
Plusieurs dizaines de troncs
d'arbre prêts à être débités.
Deux coupeurs sont là,
quelques mètres plus loin,
Et visiblement, nullement inquiétés
par notre présence.
Bonjour.
Ça va ?
Qu'est-ce que vous êtes
en train de faire ?
On ramasse du bois mort.
Allez, dis la vérité.
C'est vrai, regardez.
Et depuis combien de temps ?
Depuis trois jours.
Trois jours. D'accord.
Et ensuite tu le mets
où tout ce bois ?
Je vais le mettre sur mon bateau
et je prends la mer.
D'accord, j'ai compris.
Et ensuite tu en fais quoi ?
Tout ce bois, je vais le vendre
quand j'en aurai assez.
Autour d'eux, près d'un hectare
de mangrove détruit.
Les deux hommes ont patiemment
abattu une vingtaine d'arbres,
Sans être inquiétés un seul instant.
Vous savez que c'est interdit
ce que vous faites ?
Personne ne va nous embêter avec
des quantités de bois comme ça,
Il n'y a aucun problème.
On risque rien.
Et à qui vous revendez ça ?
Ne comptez pas sur moi
pour vous le dire.
Je ne vous donnerai pas les noms.
Vous n'avez qu'à aller vous
renseigner en ville.
C'est là-bas que vous
trouverez les patrons.
Ils ne vous diront jamais
pour qui ils travaillent.
le nom de leurs commanditaires.
Ils ont peur car ils savent très bien
que ce qu'ils font n'est pas légal.
Et comme ce n'est pas légal,
Quand on les écoute,
ils ne travaillent pour personne.
En repartant, nous découvrons
l'embarcation des deux hommes.
Plusieurs centaines de kilos de bois
attendent d'être chargés.
Ils amènent le bois de la mangrove
jusqu'ici.
Et ils vont tout charger dans le bateau
pour repartir dans la nuit,
Lorsque la marée sera haute.
Ensuite, ils débarqueront et proposeront
tout ce bois aux entreprises, aux revendeurs,
À tous ceux qui ont besoin de ce bois.
Au loin, nous apercevons d'autres coupeurs
qui complètent l'équipe,
Et reviennent avec leur chargement.
Au total, ce sont six hommes
qui se relaient jour et nuit,
Pour charger leur bateau.
Pourquoi tu fais tout ça ?
Parce qu'il n'y a pas de gaz en ville.
Alors tout ce bois va être revendu
pour faire la cuisine.
Tous les coupeurs de bois comme nous,
on est des illettrés.
À part la pêche qui rapporte plus rien,
nous n'avons pas d'autres possibilités d'emploi.
Alors couper du bois est une manière facile
pour nous, pour se faire de l'argent.
La plupart de ces gens
sont des pécheurs.
La pêche est leur principale
source de revenus.
Mais à cause de la déforestation,
Les stocks de poissons sont
en train de diminuer.
En réalité, ils créent eux-mêmes
les conditions d'un désastre,
Qui va bouleverser leur vie à l'avenir.
Mais ils n'en ont pas conscience
du tout.
Pourquoi les pêcheurs sont-ils aujourd'hui en
train de détruire ce qui les fait vivre ?
Les eaux de Karachi étaient réputées
les plus poissonneuses de la région,
Grâce à la mangrove.
Avec la déforestation, c'est tout un écosystème
qui est en train de disparaître.
Moins de poissons, donc moins
de revenus pour les pêcheurs.
Aujourd'hui, les deux tiers d'entre eux
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté.
Couper du bois est devenu pour des milliers
d'entre eux une alternative.
Un nouveau moyen de subsistance.
Dans les ruelles qui bordent le port,
Le bois ramassé se retrouve
sur tous les étals pour être revendu.
Karachi est une mégalopole où des quartiers
entiers ne bénéficient pas du gaz de ville.
Des millions de personnes ont donc besoin
de bois pour cuisiner et se chauffer.
Le bois de mangrove est particulièrement
recherché malgré son interdiction,
Car il est un bon combustible
et très bon marché.
Nous avons voulu rencontrer les organisateurs
de ce commerce illégal.
Direction un quartier
au sud de la ville,
Celui des revendeurs de bois.
Rares sont ceux qui ont
accepté de nous parler.
Cet homme nous reçoit devant l'entrepôt
qu'il tient avec son père.
On commande chaque mois 2, 3
ou même 4 tonnes.
Ça dépend de la demande
ou de la période de l'année.
On paie 4 ou 5 pêcheurs avec leur bateau
pour qu'ils rasent une partie de la mangrove,
Et après ils nous ramènent
tout le bois.
Et ça leur prend combien de temps ?
Entre dix et quinze jours.
Et après donc vous
leur achetez tout le bois ?
Oui, 5 centimes le kilo, parfois 10...
On vous a assez parler,
Laissez-nous, on a du travail.
Leur commerce marche plutôt bien.
Les trois tonnes de bois de mangrove
qu'ils achètent en moyenne chaque mois,
Se revendent deux, voire trois fois
plus cher en fonction de la demande.
Sur une année, cela leur rapporte
plus de 3 000€,
Soit deux fois le salaire moyen
au Pakistan.
Dans le quartier, nous découvrons plus
d'une centaine d'entrepôts de ce genre.
Difficile d'obtenir des informations sur
le nombre de personnes impliquées dans ce trafic,
Et sur les volumes de bois
qui sont achetés.
Tous, à mots couverts,
nous renvoient vers un nom,
Celui D'ismael Chauhan.
Il le désigne comme l'un des plus
importants commanditaire de bois de mangrove.
Il contrôlerait tout le marché avec plus
d'une centaine de coupeurs sous ses ordres.
Voici son entrepôt.
Et lorsque nous y entrons,
c'est lui qui nous accueille.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez ?
On veut juste discuter avec vous.
Rapidement, un attroupement
se forme derrière nous.
Une vingtaine d'hommes assistent
à la rencontre.
On est venu vous parler de la déforestation,
de la mangrove et de ceux qui coupent le bois.
Et alors ?
J'ai rien à vous dire. Allez voir
les pêcheurs plutôt.
Allez, c'est bon. Vous lui avez
posé assez de questions.
Il vous a dit ce qu'il avait à dire.
Vous n'avez qu'à aller au marché
si vous voulez des renseignements.
Et puis laissez-moi
vous dire une chose,
Ceux qui coupent le bois
sont des gens puissants.
Ils n'aiment pas être embêtés.
Personne ne peut les empêcher
de faire ce qu'ils font.
Une menace à peine voilée que notre traducteur
recommande de prendre au sérieux.
Ces hommes règnent en maître sur tout
le quartier, en toute impunité.
Il nous faut quitter les lieux,
sortir de la ville,
Et parcourir plusieurs kilomètres,
Pour trouver des personnes qui acceptent
de nous parler d'Ismael Chauhan,
Et de son organisation.
En fin de journée, quelques uns de ces hommes
de main nous ont donné rendez-vous.
Tous des anciens pêcheurs,
aujourd'hui coupeurs à plein temps,
Pour le compte d'Ismaël Chauhan.
Nous les filmons à leur insu.
Des gars comme Ismael, il y en a plein.
Lui possède 20 à 25 bateaux,
Et on est cinq coupeurs sur chaque bateau
quand on part dans la mangrove.
Donc quand il nous dit qu'il n'a
rien à voir avec ce trafic, c'est faux ?
Oui.
Ce qui se passe,
c'est que ce sont les industriels,
Qui donnent de l'argent à Ismael.
Ils lui disent quelle quantité de bois
ils veulent pour faire tourner les machines,
et ensuite ils passent par nous
pour tout organiser jusqu'à la livraison.
À leurs pieds,
La toute dernière commande qu'ils
s'apprêtent à livrer à Ismael Chauhan.
Du bois de mangrove qui sera
séchée puis découpée,
Et enfin mélangée à d'autres variétés
de bois jusqu'à en perdre sa trace.
C'est ainsi que chaque année,
chez les revendeurs,
Plusieurs milliers de tonnes de bois
de mangrove sont écoulées sur le marché,
En toute légalité.
Les autorités de Karachi semblent
fermer les yeux sur ce trafic.
Pourtant, les projections
les plus pessimistes affirment,
Que la mangrove est
en voie de disparition.
Pour les responsables de l'Office
des forêts, qui étudie son évolution,
Relevés satellites à l'appui,
La déforestation de la mangrove
s'est accélérée ces dernières années,
principalement autour de Karachi,
Et personne ne peut l'enrayer.
Voici les zones les plus touchées.
Tout ce que vous voyez en rouge
correspond à des forêts denses.
Et petit à petit, regardez là les zones
où la mangrove se dégrade.
À Karachi, la mangrove est coupée
dans le but de s'approprier des terres.
Quand il n'y a plus d'arbres,
on remblais et alors on peut construire.
Ce sont des terres très précieuses.
Et c'est pour ça que la
déforestation s'accélère.
Ceux qui coupent pour récupérer
du bois de chauffage, c'est rien.
En réalité, tous les coupeurs sont utilisés
par les intermédiaires et les commanditaires.
Plus de 7000 hectares de mangroves, l'équivalent
en superficie d'une ville comme Paris,
Disparaissent chaque année sous
le coup de la pression immobilière.
Autant de nouvelles terres
pour de nouvelles constructions.
On se retrouve confronté
à une mafia de l'immobilier !
Une véritable mafia qui englobe
jusqu'aux hommes politiques.
Cette mafia prospère car les terres
sont rares et donc chères.
Vous donnez quelques dizaines d'euros
aux coupeurs pour faire leur travail,
Mais la terre que vous récupérez
peut vous rapporter une fortune.
Et ça fait 50 ans que ça dure ici !
Dans 10 ans, Karachi deviendra l'une
des plus grandes villes au monde,
Avec une population estimée
à 20 millions d'habitants.
Aux portes de la ville,
les marques de son extension,
La mangrove recule et finit par
disparaître face à l'avancée du béton.
Jour après jour,
La petite armée des coupeurs
la vide de sa substance,
Dans l'indifférence.
Sans imaginer qu'un jour
elle puisse complètement disparaître.
Les habitants, de **** non plus, n'ont jamais
imaginé que cela puisse arriver un jour.
Située au cœur du delta de l'Indus,
100 kilomètres au sud de Karachi,
leur village, n'est plus qu'une fine bande de
terre menacée par la montée des eaux.
Année après année, ils ont assisté, impuissants,
à la disparition de leur unique richesse,
La mangrove qui les entourait
et les protégeait.
À 40 ans, Ayub, le chef du village,
a passé la moitié de sa vie ici.
Et il craint de devoir partir bientôt,
Quand l'eau recouvrira
définitivement les habitations.
Il y a 20 ans, on vivait
au milieu d'une jungle dense.
Il y avait beaucoup d'arbres.
Et un petit canal qui nous a amenés à la mer,
qui était loin, très loin.
Maintenant, la jungle a été ravagée,
la mer monte,
Et la mangrove recule de plus en plus.
Ayub porte aujourd'hui un projet,
utopique peut-être,
Mais qui redonne espoir à la centaine
de familles du village.
Sur ces étendues de boue, il a décidé
de replanter des graines de mangrove,
Pour tenter de redonner vie à la forêt,
Qui autrefois les entourait.
Chaque semaine, aidée par
les enfants du village,
Ayub plante les graines, une à une.
Rangée par rangée.
Un travail de fourmi qui permettra de
recouvrir plusieurs kilomètres carrés.
Tous ces arbres vont
ramener les poissons,
Et vont nous protéger contre
les cyclones et les inondations.
Ce sont nos arbres.
Et cette fois-ci, on ne laissera
personne les abattre.
- Vous en êtes convaincus ?
- J'en suis sûr.
Ces arbres mettront cinq ans pour grandir,
Et sauveront alors peut-être
le village d'Ayub et des siens.